[Musique]
on se retrouve à côté du père lachaise
aujourd'hui on va les voir cros cole
gros scotch pas si vous connaissez une
marque de smartphones outdoor ya des
choses à nous raconter aujourd'hui en
france comme j'étais parti avec eux il
ya quelques jours il ya quelques mois
déjà
on était parti je me suis là chamonix
pour aller voir l'utmb c'est la course
de l'extrême ont tous les fous furieux
aujourd'hui dont des nouveautés à nous
montrer du côté des tablettes est a
priori
regardez on n'est pas loin du cimetière
du père lachaise morrison plein de
célèbres personnes et illustres inconnus
qui reposaient terminale
[Musique]
regardez ce que j'ai dans la main comme
ça se passe comme ça c'est mieux comme
ça bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler trop
apparaître au score j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas dans l'écran alors qu'en
fait il est absolument accrocher
c'est juste histoire de me la péter un
petit poucet radio cros cols rouges ou
autres skol uhel gars
salut dernière quand je vous dis view
était sur une forte baisse des super dur
on est dans la tempête sexy à laon pour
la foudre quand on est sur un truc un
peu de métal tu vois on va tous crever
en est une belle marque en ce sens
vachement fataliste non mais oui non
voilà donc en acier sous tente un seul
ouvrage tout va bien
rappel j'ai entendu parler de finale on
va lui montrer ce bordel
il y avait moi tranquille il en pleine
récupération la paire aghmari le prévoit
le règlement film
vous avez la nouvelle tablette est
carrément dans un bloc de glace on l'a
regardé sans qu'aucune est complètement
glace et congelés de tous les côtés mais
ce qui était drôle ce qu'ils ont mis le
numéro de téléphone appelez-moi
qu'entraîne la plaie
ah mais non on attendait mais rend au
bureau blouin table et je vais le voir
flotter tu me fais bosser sur de la post
prod commencé à chamonix va super bien
ouais on est fier de présenter cette
nouvelle gamme
tu peux c'est cool
très content de vous revoir
il n'allait pas du fromage conduit
navire petit apéritif post départ utm
mais durant du fromage fondu quoi c'est
pas bien ouais bah du coup une fois un
gros ver rouge
j'ai besoin d'un gros verte a pas grover
j'ai une grosse foire
ça me rappelle les montagnes suisses et
brenna la suite à des coups que la
langue dessus il ya moyen d'avoir un
style
c'est bon la technologie c'est très bon
un petit classement avec à perrier c'est
toujours
alors là là là
la toile est bien d'accord je t'ai vu tu
leur histoire wang
[Musique]
le signal
la bonne humeur et la non là c'est pas
la même ambiance et voilà on a appris
sur la course ouvrant cette fois c'est
moi du coup oui ça c'est ça c'est ça
marche sportive
exane nouveaux produits de nouveaux
produits 3d motion
une nouvelle tablette dans
beauté pour consoles et parce que j'ai
zappé donc on voit un petit cadeau pour
le coes quatre notes photos de gamme
quant à gages voilà la navette voilà adc
ya dans un petit sac ou walter
merci à toi
cela dit oui regardez-moi ça comme c'est
beau on vient de l'agencement protocole
avec mon bon vieux pote mister perrier
salut à tous salle de vienne où seul un
stop ariel vous connaissez sap
on a déjà fait des vidéos ses débuts
chez toi salut les cocos c'est mister
perrier qui coule j'étais en train de me
piquer du travail sur nos chaînes c'est
ma chaîne la wes voix étaient abonnés
alors je veux me piquer tous les abonnés
oui on se connaissait pas qu'ils
m'avaient invité alors je m'étais invité
chez toi il m'avait dit bien manger bien
manger et cuisine pas mal ensuite vous
savez comme moi et là regardez on allait
tous parce qu'on coûte le corps ex-cat
donc ça je vais aller tester je vous
dirai tout moi je sais lire les le
nouveau design de leurs voix c'est très
éco responsable ce trou oui tu vois le
côté papier carton recyclable et recyclé
très probablement c'est cool surtout ce
produit là c'est le corps p4c marqué ici
comme le port salut les gars
d'expression désignés designated en
france alors ouais tu vois ces sportifs
jusqu'à la boîte c'est ça c'est à dire
que pour une journée en fait ça te fait
les muscles mais bon c est coresponsable
ça marche donc ça c'est bien pas mal pas
mal donc on va s'ouvrir un peu s'en va
se regarder ça aujourd'hui premier
aperçu et puis je vous dirais vraiment
ce que j'en pense parce que je trouve
que le projet prenne vraiment monsieur
pari est un pari impossible mais c'est
pareil oui bien sûr vous abonner à la
chaîne de l'histoire paris merci je vous
mets le lien ça vient d'ailleurs je vous
mets le lien dans la description vous le
papa lé là je crois que c'est là donc la
bonne voie la chaîne the mist pas parlé
parce qu'après tout le match mais un
coup à découvrir et sa chaîne allait
vraiment vraiment sympa donc aujourd'hui
on sait ce que ça et puis toi t'es juste
de passage pour l'événement fait
exactement turpin pour visiter ton
magnifique son magnifique studio si on a
un pilier donc le pilier creux du livre
ici on a donc un magnifique rideau qui
va pouvoir servir aussi à une isolation
phonique pour les futurs pas de cloud je
pense que le rythme des gages et
honnêtement il va dégager oui par contre
il est très doux très soyeux et ce n'est
pas sponsorisé ici donc il ya mon
futur don précieux voilà mon futur
précieux et là c'est monsieur ça ne
saurait tarder si vous vous abonnez
abonnez vous vite pour que mr perrier
ils sont trop fait décent kallio s'est
ici on a un coin donc le boxing
on va vérifier le pied parce que des
fois ça peut être très joli mais ah oui
ça c'est du costaud chez monsieur gros
c'est du costaud
on n'est pas en suisse mais presque ici
donc quatre jeunes hommes très très
poilu capillairement ici à mesure que je
vais bientôt être aménagé oui parce que
là j'ai tous les produits nanos leaf
canevas tout le mur comme ça va être un
analyste avait trop cool merci youtube
donc ici petites caméras de surveillance
parce que la sécurité avant tout de chez
chuo me voilà voilà petit coup un
montage avec enceintes yamaha et bien
l'adresse du tuba bien sûr que je n'ai
pas oui ma peine
mag a pris ma fille aussi gros dans le
dos non sérieux le dessus
non mais gainey c'était lors de mémoire
est bonne bonne rentrée et on a le coin
love family
ça c'est du mur chez monsieur grrrr je
vous ai dit que c'était du solide dans
quoi continuer suivez le soigner
alors votre micro scope nous présente au
genre de mission on peut y aller avec
roscoff produits sont extrêmement
résistant ça c est le corps x 4 core ix
4 design est en france je vais lui testé
je verrai si je vous fais une vidéo
youtube pas forcément peut-être impôts
est intéressant en tout cas je
regarderai je vous dirais vraiment si ça
vaut le coup oui ou non c'est tout ça
c'est le produit qui moi ça me va
falloir beaucoup plus large c'est se
produire qui m'intéresse vraiment moi
c'est le corps t4 alors c'est avec les
relais dans la gamme qu on comprend
encore corps et dans cette gamme là il
ya la gamme trekkeurs il ya la gamme
actionne la gamme core c'est plutôt la
gamme qui est destiné aux pros et là on
est sur une tablette qui est vraiment
increvable donc si vous êtes créateur
vous partez que vous aimez du conte
visionner du contenu multimédia
compagnie et que vous voulez un produit
increvable résistant par tout ça c'est
probablement ce qu'il vous faut attendre
dix mois envers ce truc comment ça
marche
voilà ça c'est la tablette je sais pas
si vous avez connu si vous soutenu
trekkeurs x4 on retrouve vraiment ce
design c'est très racée c'est très typé
c'est très particulier
je l'enlève on tient une main si on veut
mais faut vraiment avoir envie
on peut venir ici branches et tous les
accessoires avec le ixlink directement
de crosse colle donc ça c'est cool vous
pouvez le poser ça peut tenir dans
différentes circonstances nous le marque
bien si la caméra l'arrière 13
mégapixels ça ça doit être un un flash
qui est assez énorme tout ça c'est quoi
ça c'est la grosse vis sévices et il ya
vraiment un côté extrêmement solide
robuste et résistante donne envie en
tout cas c'est vraiment rassurant comme
produit bouton de volume tout au privé
pour éteindre un bouton dédié si ça joue
vraiment prendre le temps de découvrir
tu le prennes bien comme s'attaque voilà
de quoi venir recharger directement ici
en usb si vous avez une batterie 7000
milliampères à l'intérieur ils ont fait
un truc qui est absolument incroyable
c'est un bouton ici on à tiroirs de
cartes sim ah ça c'est pas mal ça
d'avoir laissé une prise jack
à l'intérieur de la boîte le x bloqueurs
alors l'idée chez cros colle si vous
prenez votre x bloqueurs vous venez le
maître d'un côté et de l'autre vous
mettrez vos accessoires vous mettez
votre x bloqueurs salle tiens ça ne
bouge pas vous attacher sur un voeu sur
ce que vous voulez ce assez résistant
charger de 10 watts pourquoi pas mais
les 15000 batterie de 7000 millions
terreur ça me paraît quand même tout
petit ici j'ai mon câble usb c'est usb
des petits écouteurs des autocollants
histoire de parler de la marque
ok cros colle ça roule haddock
bon ça c'est bien ok
[Musique]
moi tout de suite des cadets aux écolos
je deviens complètement
alors qu'est ce qu'elle nous fait cette
tablette comme promesse c'est la toute
première est extrêmement résistante vous
pouvez l'acheter d'un mètre cinquante de
hauteur sans aucun problème elle
craindre à ses regards d'aller pas de
marque rien du tout sarsgaard marché
comme ça aussi voilà la belle quand elle
est à vimeo via les produits leurs
bourses avec en termes de design c'est
normal c'est cros colm freyne des
grandes bord durant aux grandes bordure
en bas ils seront cherche pas le
borderless ont cherché si la solidité on
cherche la robustesse que votre qui
craignent absolument pas on tourne sur
android version 9 vous avez cité de
mettre une double carte sim
ici la planque est ici à l'intérieur
après ça marche comme une tablette
android classique 1 vous avez vos
applications taquet qui sont planqués
ici j'aime bien le fond d'écran c'est
assez marrant le côté lave comme ça ça
contraste bien avec le produit c'est
assez joli bon il faut le temps je la
prenne un petit format peu j'apprenne
vraiment l'apprivoiser mais bon pourquoi
je trouve cool elle prend des shoots est
toujours là elle existe c'est vraiment
la donne de ce produit alors évitez de
faire tomber sur un coin de cailloux ici
parce qu'au bout d'un moment vous
risquez quand même de la pt mais sinon
sur le principe
le produit est fait vraiment côté
extrêmement résistant moi je vous fasse
un peu l'histoire à l'ap sucre aux cols
ont fait ce qu'ils savent faire c'est à
dire c'est un produit qui va je vais
dire un smartphone une tablette un
produit qui est aussi bon pour
l'extérieur que pour l'intérieur vous
pouvez emmener partout à l' aventure
avec vous pour vous soyez à court ni de
batterie lille rien intérieur pour tous
des solutions professionnelles parce que
vous avez un truc qui est résistant
je pense à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans le btp dans les
industries et compagnie vous risquez pas
de le casser lorsque vous allez
l'échappée faire tomber aucun produit
qui va tomber dessus ensuite vous avez
le côté extérieur vous pouvez l'emmener
soit de l'outdoor vous partez j'en sais
rien moi sur un trait à exporter dans
l'himalaya où que ce soit elle craindra
pas le froid ça c'est cool et c'est
extrêmement rassurant donc là-dessus
cros cole fait du cros cole ils prennent
ce qu'ils savent faire sera format
smartphone sans tracker x4 il vous met
là dessus sur une tablette donc ça
fonctionne alors bien évidemment elle
est résistante à l'eau et à la poussière
c'est grand minimum à une certification
de grades militaires vous avez un
corning gorilla glass de 1,5 mm à
l'avant donc faut quand même y aller
comme un sauvage pour aussi de la péter
on a un écran de 8 pouces format 16/10
par contre c'est un produit qui est un
peu épais vous n'allez pas chercher la
finesse chicros cole là dessus on a
essayé 14 mm d'épaisseur vous pouvez
mettre une double sim parce que oui il
faut mettre des cartes sim là dedans
c'est plutôt cool pour le projet majine
pro particulier plus une carte micro sd
pour augmenter la capacité du produit
que bluetooth 4.1 ici et pas de tout ce
5.0 il nous annonce se débandent
européenne donc vous pouvez emmener
partout en europe est connecté partout
sans aucun problème quand je parle
d'europe et même dans le monde entier
doit quand même couvrir suffisamment
large
c'est un produit qui donnait pour la
robustesse et pour la polyvalence est au
tarif de 499 euros et 90 centimes alors
c'est pas un produit qui est destiné à
tout le monde si vous dites je vais
m'acheter une tablette vous allez pas
acheté ce produit là ce produit là vous
allez l'acheter si vous en avez un
besoin spécifique c'est pas le produit
qu'il est le meilleur pour aller faire
des photos c'est pas le produit qui va
être le meilleur pour avoir beaucoup de
fluidité beaucoup d'arôme ans c'est par
contre un produit que vous allez emmener
partout avec vous sauf qu'elle est
pouvoir compter en permanence c'est
vraiment ce qu'on vient chercher et
d'ailleurs voyais un truc qui m'a assez
bluffé c'est qu'en fait ils ont annoncé
que la part d' avril 2020 et bien la
sncf avait choisi comme à paris pour
tous ces contrôleurs les trekkeurs x4
c'est plutôt au fait de se dire que cros
cole était en compétition avec de très
grands du domaine cd samsung compagnie
ici et ça c'est cros cole qui a remporté
le marché et qui avec strecker x4 va
équiper la sncf et toute la flotte
effectivement de contrôleurs sncf ont
bien bossé habitera car ils savent
qu'avec ce produit vous avez une
garantie de trois ans précise vous savez
ne vous ai déjà une garantie 2 ans la
garantie de deux ans et la garantie de
base de la garantie constructeur de 1
ensuite vous avez la garantie européenne
qui vous emmène jusqu'à deux ans et des
microscopes tout ce truc un peu plus
loin dans ok nous regardons été jusqu'à
trois ans pour que les produits soient
durables c'est vraiment la durabilité
c'était le mot qu'ils ont beaucoup
utilisé ça fait très très marketing mais
en fait je pense que c'est un vrai sens
qu'on doit que le packaging qui sont
dans les matières recyclées et
recyclables
là vous avez un produit qui doit durer
longtemps qu'il va durer dans le temps
cros causes sont pas non plus des
nouveaux produits tous les ans c'est des
produits dont ils sont censés durer
jusqu'à attendre le mois la prochaine
génération qui va pas forcément arriver
tout ceci parce qu'elle beaucoup
d'investissements pourra sortir un
produit comme celui là je ne pars en
tout cas avoir un sens apparaît plutôt
bien aller dans le bon sens dans le sens
du progrès dans le sens de la marche
ça c'est cool donc voilà pour cette
première découverte prise en main de ce
nous
aux produits l'accord t4 pratiquement
commentaire en voix est ce que vous ne
vous en parle de celui là est ce que ça
vous intéresse consult est est ce que ça
vous botte qu'on regarde ce qu'il est
capable de faire le corps x4 qu'on le
prenne congé de tous les côtés par les
fenêtres des drones thèse qu'on le jette
et puis voir voilà qu'elles sont un
petit peu de civilité dites moi ça en
bas en commentaire quant à nous on
continue à paraître très rapidement il
n'y a pas tué a raconté
et puis on va jeter un coup d'oeil de
s'excuser je pense que ça va être
vraiment cool sur ce livret vie de
l'amour à demain
[Musique]